in order to make a really good sound
system for our customers we need to meet
many aspects of sound quality number one
is tonal balance enough Basin of travel
Etc but also stereo Imaging you also
want to load distortion and you want to
be able to play Loud if all of these
four things are really strong then it's
really a great sound system
[Music]
and what you call a full anechoic
chamber this is basically a room with
these conical shaped acoustic panels on
the walls ceiling and the floor these
panels we absorb sound Reflections so
this is where we do all our prototype
design testing trying to design the most
effective solution for our vehicles
in order to decide for the location of a
speaker there are different aspects when
a speaker is for high or mid frequencies
it's very important that it's in the
right spot for low frequencies the spot
is less important it's more important
that it has a really rigid mounting so
that's where these decisions are made
this is a subwoofer from a model Y and
there are a couple remarkable things
about this the the first is how large it
is and that large volume contributes
directly to the performance of the
subwoofer in the car this is a nice
demonstration of how tightly integrated
the subwoofer is into the surrounding
interior components and what that
results in is a lot of interior cabin
space
this is an app we have which exposes a
little bit more of what the DSP is
digital signal processing is available
in the car and so we're using this for
Diagnostics so we can kind of come into
a car and quickly figure out is there a
problem with this car how's it sounding
by turning some things on and off when
we tune the car we're going to take a
bunch of measurements measurements in
each seat and then we'll know the
impulse response from the speaker to the
listening position we can figure out
what the best filters are going to be so
that each person in each seat is going
to have a great listening experience
this is Tessie our head and torso
simulator it's used to tune telephony it
has a speaker in the mouth and
microphones in the ears so it can
acoustically do everything a human could
do the measurements are done first and
then in the second level we really
listen to it and do fine adjustments
[Music]
so most people spend time in their cars
listening to music but Tesla is special
because you also have video and gaming
capabilities very few cars currently let
you do that with the subwoofer and the
woofers in the car the effects of
watching a movie it sounds much bigger
than the screen or the car so people
definitely enjoy it
I think the really unique thing is the
amount of design and development that we
do in-house internal teams at Tesla work
extremely closely together in order to
optimize all sorts of systems in the car
including the audio system why I became
a DSP engineer is that you can work on
an algorithm you can do a bunch of math
but then you get to listen to it your
Tesla is the place that you go to listen
to audio it's not like a compromise it's
like where you choose to go to listen to
your audio most blokes their car audio
only goes to 10 but in a Tesla you can
go one Higher to 11.